brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com from recore we headed into the
biggest one of the biggest bombshell
quotes of perhaps of this e3 your xbox
360 games will be playable natively on
your xbox one megaton reggaeton is huge
that is absolutely huge is credibly in
fury inconsiderate just put all those
games away oh I think this is a
fantastic initiative by Microsoft it
really is going to win a lot of fans
over everyone and their brother have an
xbox 360 right everyone has that
everyone has a massive collection of
xbox 360 game my sister's even got an
xbox your sister has an extra even have
everyone hello so you know I think it's
a great idea there was a great digger
Sony because and I think I look quite
deserved one because PlayStation now is
streamed games that we already own like
a price you know and they said you could
play your old game for free on xbox one
that was a big shots fired there there's
some shots we won't charge you to play
games you already own a lot so that of
course raises the question how ya can't
imagine them being like yo yeah cuz they
say okay you have your disc put the disc
in download it to your xbox one and then
you can play what you can't imagine them
just letting anyone with a game disc use
it cuz then have you get around use
rental market becomes a whole different
day and you could just pass it around
and I don't know it's that's the kind of
free license that platform holders have
been really reluctant to give up in this
generation of consoles however they were
also reluctant to talk about any kind of
backwards compatibility and now we're
seeing it implemented so what do you
guys think how surprising how far
Microsoft's come from trying to lock
down like the pre-owned market to this
point way seems like they just
completely reverses compared to this
bleep I get the feeling that there's
going to be some caveats that they just
don't want to dig into because it would
kind of a disagreement I think I think
they're going to be open about something
I think I'm gonna be totally cool about
it I definitely think they're going to
detail and they're going to be open
about it but I think they don't want to
go into the nitty gritties where one
every city has every game has a unique
code that wanted to use is gone like
they don't want to talk about that
because they think is that they're not
gonna make any money on backwards
compatibility this is never gonna be
about money I mean it up sells the xbox
one slightly yes but this is this is
about fanservice right this is about
their engineers doing loads of software
emulation on the back end so we can play
our old games this isn't about selling
or do you reckon I everyone will be able
to just pass around the same game and
yeah I think that's going to be actually
fine i think a few publishers who would
re-releasing digital deluxe editions
gonna be a bit annoyed that the
originals are now going to be available
matrox one or they might just not make
them available because it's yeah ha
generous it's not gonna require any more
development to make them at work but it
does require dev approval right so
though I just I or yeah well oh yeah the
game to the poor you know whoever
happens to own that bright license needs
to approve it it's not just let's put
everything else so it was a bit like
share play where Sony was like oh this
is gonna be great you can just track you
could play games online of your friends
all the time and then every publisher
went now you know you're not doing yeah
very really interesting to see how
that's going to work out that's xbox one
backwards compatibility with the xbox
360 Wow big huge uh then we've got a
look at the elite controller mm-hmm the
xbox elite controller what did you guys
I was running a new story out of time so
I was kind of looking up and down and
basically every time I looked up the
controller was just like in bits I'm not
completely sure what's happening there
someone's gonna blame yeah that's the
domed analog stick for the concave one
if you want or the d-pad I think was the
most sort of eye-catching is that uh
that like little Basin that had
different angles so it was again it was
like a little hole to sort of our cave
to rest your thumb in and then move
around from there I'll be really happy
if either i have some kind of other
bumpers that i can stick in there or
some bumper alternative because the
bumpers are the thing I hate the most on
the xbox one controller oh right i said
i would really love to get something in
there but i think also something to note
was that they it says compatible with
xbox one and Windows 10 like right there
on the screen son of a takes a shine off
Microsoft's
no Microsoft's team's new controller
right if it's kind of got like it looks
like for example that bit day it looks
like almost like a mouse pad area and so
if it could do if they could add that
kind of functionality into it it could
kind of crossover and then let make it
more to it for pc play i am slightly
amazed that if you could make any but
personally if I could make any
modification to the xbox one controller
i would add in lithium batteries or like
yeah recharge abilities terribly but
this appears to be a lot of battery case
very casing yeah they're going hard on
Barry casing it does look I mean there's
gonna be a lot of third-party you know
peripheral makers out there creating
custom bits and it's a good way to
customize your own controller like I do
you know people love buying the halo
version of a control if they could just
release like a halo you know d pad or
something like that it's a good way to
for Microsoft and for peripheral makers
to make you money and give people chance
to express themselves through their
control yourself don't just put a
sticker on it cuz they rub off I also
it's got those tabs on the back you guys
ever play with a controller with these
things because they're definitely in use
in competitive circles yeah because it's
a way to get more button access without
taking your thumb off the analog start
to press the buttons I you know I don't
have you tried it I've never tries I
mean the last time I saw something like
that was when call of duty hacking is a
big thing and people were adding in
shortcuts in the back just so they can
do weird like 360 noscopes and that kind
of stuff but I was extra buttons that's
where that's how I could do it tomorrow
I knew it I'm you aware that bad all
this time but yeah I've never used by me
I'm definitely intrigued like it opens
up the with like more strategy games
arriving and that kind of thing it could
open up a lot of possibilities with
shortcuts and that kind of thing
programmable buttons yeah it's
definitely interesting right on xbox
elite controller for xbox one and
Windows 10 coming sometime
you